so the great towel shall be it's gonna
build a car to beat Ferrari with a fool
correct and how long did you tell them
you needed two or three hundred years 90
days gentlemen please tell me y'all got
to do some actual racing and driving in
these cars during the filming of a
little bit enough that we got to do
enough but not enough that we ruined the
movie man because you really want the
race scenes to be like this really
exciting so when when when the real
stuff had to go down they put the real
drivers in there is their race training
that you have to do for something like
this just even to know the
technicalities as an actor yeah yeah I
don't know about I don't if every actor
would say you have to do it but I didn't
feel very confident unless I did and so
yes I did go do a driving school for a
week yeah with the great Bob ponder on
how fast you get your cars up to no idea
I don't look at the speed I don't you I
mean now I heard they read right
I heard the stunt guys sander even when
we were on the biskits we would be going
about 120 yeah yeah yeah on that but you
know we didn't reach 230 which he's
welcome ours reached do you remember
your first car yeah of course I have a
salvage it was an 89 Acura Integra LS
and it's been in an accident and it was
used so I got a good deal on it did you
have one of those because almost every
person who match says yeah the acura
integra goes I'd want to know I had a
Honda Civic which is like the x-wing of
earth everyone had one at some point in
their life and I taught your director
had a Volkswagen Rabbit Tracy had a
Mercury Cougar and Bernthal had a Mazda
3 2 3 something and if we take all the
cars and actually do a limb on race who
wins the Integra is interesting that
could but Bernthal is pretty confident
is driving ability in that little Mazda
I love take them take them down and I'm
gonna take him in the Buick I've got a
big go and a big stop it is fun because
y'all are two of the biggest action
stars on the planet right now which is
how we talk about ourselves hello hello
Philip biggest action
thing we would think of actually hey but
but i but you know yeah after you ready
this fight and realize where it were
we're two tips up shape [ __ ] yeah I was
gonna say how do you dumb down your
training over the years doesn't take it
you just get older that's how you'd
manage that we were trying out bloody
hardest in that fight I have to ask this
you can make the answer as short as you
want
born Batman who wins in a fight love
love yeah I think I think we have to
find yeah they found he's retired from
Batman I've retired from but like there
they found peace they've they're they're
gonna be in a nursing home together
someday I'm gonna get along let me let
me spend a different way because mangled
said that Wolverine would win isn't that
have you seen Hugh Jackman up close I
would not tangle with that guy alright
so let's get back to the first car this
could be any point your life longest
road trip you ever went on like LeMond
without taking a break you can stop for
gas but without sleeping I drove across
the country within an RV when I was when
I was 19 with my dad and my brother and
Ben and another friend of ours and we
the RV didn't stop you know we went
probably the first 36 hours without
stopping we're just sleeping and taking
[ __ ] did you have like just to hold him
the floor your feet out it was a
bathroom it was a big one yeah yes he
takes shifts or two people would drive
and then he could go up at the top and
sleep or in the back and sleep those it
was so 19 hours Christian I don't say 19
hours ever sorry this taking 17 hours
away from Tracy was 19 hours but he's
probably talking about like driving in a
car without sleeping for 19 hours and
that's probably there's probably like a
lot of speed involved right not just the
wheels going around no VW campervan
about three days but it wasn't non-stop
driving or stopping and sleeping in the
w camp event yeah right congratulations
you get the way finally read something
from Rotten Tomatoes that's the good
news that I could bring home no whatever
it is she'll know trust me so I look at
this movie from a racing perspective as
a film that is pushing the limits of
what you can do as a director are you
pushing the limits as to how you can
cinematically portray a racing sequence
because there's some mind-blowing stuff
in here um we tried our best to do the
most dynamic stuff we could and I think
technology was on our side not CG
technology but just even the physical
technology the gear we can shoot
fast-moving cars with I mean I've made
commercials for years as well as
directed movies and and I made a couple
car commercials and the gear that is
available to shoot moving vehicles is
pretty amazing now I'm the kind of fluid
heads and shock-absorbing heads and
gimballed heads mounted on two
high-speed cars they call this thing the
Russian arm you know these car these
vehicles that will drive they can go at
over 100 miles an hour with an with an
actual crane arm attached with the
camera balanced and never shaking
cruising two inches from the vehicle
next to it it's incredible the shots you
can make and also the miniaturization of
cameras now allows us to put cameras in
all sorts of places you couldn't have
before which all fulfilled my goal of
trying to put the audience in the race
so much of I think the reason some
people don't enjoy Motorsports
is the fact that as a viewing experience
you're kind of locked out of everything
interesting you're just watching cars go
just are just watching cars go around in
a circle but in this movie you're inside
the car where the character you love
understanding what they're up against
the brakes are failing the rain is
pouring there's a driver trying to knock
them off the road you're feeling at
first person from their shoes and that's
the other thing I mean I'd send people
to the theater to see this for the
racing sequences and I'd say find the
best theater you can in your town but
you also have two of the biggest action
stars on the planet and what I loved
about the house film is that you get to
direct a fight scene between them what
they called the pathetic fight scene
what Christian and Matt good I know
these two guy who beat up so many bad
guys on
screen that we need a step oh there were
so eat they were pushovers if they love
the idea they're so over the over
choreographed hyper super bacio every
punch sends a guy with a pull of a you
know a repeller rope into the wall and
leaves a dent all the kind of [ __ ]
fighting sequences that we've seen this
was in a way doing what it really looks
like what a bunch of guys get in a bar
fight you have not been at a bunch of
bar fights you such a bruiser
Wonderbread so I do have to ask you
because you've superhero experience who
wins in a fight if it's Jason Bourne
versus Batman there's just you know how
many times I'm asked this question and
how different many ways I've tried to
avoid it and I'm gonna continue the I
have no idea nor do I even care they're
both they're both retired some from
those characters but the fact is I have
no idea depends what Batman's bought it
brought on his utility belt that day I
guess so we can agree Logan to face the
winner though yeah Logan would defeat
both of them let's talk about a
chemistry between them for a minute
because you have these two great stars
and they're fantastic actors but when is
a director do you know onset oh this is
really working from a character
interaction standpoint you don't know
ever until you're shooting and then you
can feel it but the reality is that
these are two guys who really like each
other and really are also known both of
them for 20 years now they're great guys
they love their work their generous
actors and I think they both really
admire the [ __ ] out of each other on top
of that the characters are really good
for them and they're really different
you know Matt's kind of a Salesman a
kind of Zen master of chess playing
Texas character Christian's Brummie kind
of brawler a little bit of Asperger's II
kind of hard time getting along
expressing himself almost to no filter
super driven there there's such a great
sense of sparks just between the way
they're delineating last question first
car you ever owned
Volkswagen Rabbit so sad it's not
winning woman no it's not it's not even
winning my I wish that could be saying
something exciting mr. Ford Ferrari has
a message for you sir what did they say
she said Ford makes ugly little cars and
ugly factories and God you fat sir
gentlemen from the Ford corporation
standpoint there's a number of things
not even I knew going into the movie and
I own a Ford Fusion so the two of you
how much research and preparation was
required to play your legendary roles
look a lot is it is laid out there in
the script I I think for me look there's
there's a wealth of stuff out there
about Lee and it was really but it
didn't really it was a real real joy to
read about about Lee and and and and to
watch old videos about Lee but you know
this that that was when he was a Titan
of industry and a household name and
bristling with with with confidence and
you know people say he could have been
elected president I mean he was he's an
unbelievable man and I think that to
take all that and play him at a very
very different time in his life in very
very different circumstances it really
you know research it's it's not really
about research it's it's it's about sort
of trying to execute Jimmy's vision and
bring your own imagination and and what
would you your own heart into it yeah
not a lot of research didn't require it
it was on the page and the dramaturgy
was on the page well there was something
that your character required that was
such an enjoyable sequence for me is
when henry ford ii gets in the race car
and he has this emotional moment that
just runs the gamut of every feeling you
could have from fear to laughter to tear
crying what place do you go to as a
performer to get that out of you
well it helps that first of all that the
scene is well-written and it helps that
Jim mangled provided
the circumstances all the underpinnings
to be able to do the scene I mean we are
actually in a car and the car is
actually travelling very fast up to a
hundred miles an hour and spending
around and stopping and then the cameras
are already mounted on the car so we're
able to just proceed straight in the
scene with all the adrenaline that we're
feeling from the ride we've taken great
fun
I do remember your first car what it was
78 Mercury Cougar ok so your director
had a Volkswagen Rabbit and so I'm
trying to think of everybody's car who
would win at LeMans so now we have
American Cougars gonna take out that
rabbit I had a I had a five-speed Mazda
3 2 3 and like you know like they say in
the movie it's not really it's not only
about the cards about the driver and I
would bet on myself my CC role Jon
Bernthal yeah he pushed the limits
because Lamont is a 24-hour race so I
wanted to ask y'all your personal
experience longest you've ever driven a
car without a break on a road trip
you can break for gas but right Oh sleep
16 hours well just driving away yeah you
know driving cross-country yeah 16 hours
yeah I think I'm not sure ever made of
16 hours yeah I've done I've done right
around that 16 18 so some I want to be a
little bit higher than Tracy so I'm
gonna go ahead and say 18 but yeah I'm
around was 1900 shakin best of 19 that
19 hours 15 minutes was that was into
Wyoming um no but I Drive I won the 24
hours yes he did I didn't I wish he left
that part out gosh
[Music]